you've seen her and oh god you've seen
her in the Black Stallion you saw her in
Tootsie Close Encounters of the Third
Kind you saw her and mr. mom you seen
her in tonight's opening number this
woman really works a lot and with good
reason here she is to present the award
for achievement in makeup Teri Garr
I want to show you some before and after
pictures of three actors may we have the
mug shots please Danny Glover Eric
Stoltz and Joel Grey what happened
between the before and after is the work
of the nominees for the achievement in
makeup and they are Ken chase for the
color purple
Michael Westmore and Zoltan attack for
masks
carl fullerton for Remo Williams the
adventure begins
Michael Westmore and
this is really exciting this is and I
know it is for Zoltan because he's my
buddy and he's from Hungary and he's
we're all excited about the project mast
but we'd like to thank the members of
the Academy I'd like to thank all my
friends at Hollywood magic we're not
supposed to thank our kids but Michael
and Michelle you can put the x-rated
film in now and put Mackenzie to bed I'd
like to thank all the people at
Universal who made the project possible
Frank price Martin stargher Howard
Alston Peter Bogdanovich it was a thrill
working with all of them and the biggest
thrill to me is that of course my family
name has been in the business for years
but it's kind of gotten lost over the
years with all the new people coming in
and I've had a lot of relatives have
done a lot of wonderful things and all I
can say is for the guys that have gone
on before that I I love you and the
families got one thank you
now I start to believe my dream came
true she was a very long way from
Hungary to here but I have to thank to
all those people who have been helping
me and believe in me thank you again
thank you